Oh screw the world Wow right there with
you fair stranger oh I was about to ask
you the same thing but some idiot
who called himself a gentleman I could
best me in a do me - I know I didn't
understand a word you said but I think I
agree with you drink with me oh I dare
say you're daft Pratt and I challenge
you again to another duel you really
want to do this again yes the one who
lose all of your money a second time
we've got nothing left to lose we
literally have no money left I thought
you had five dollars in your pocket we
don't think you'll see [ __ ] my friend or
Nothing why did I will be reading that
this this is not in your five dollars
you didn't see anything
you're not fooling anyone alright let's
play the damn game then I didn't work at
all okay so this is max gentlemen if you
know about stylish hats which I don't
think you should Apple knows everything
about well dad doesn't know anything
about anything
but if you did know it's about stacking
hats which means that you need to select
your character Oh
consider the Hat stack so my baldness
will be known to the world now I feel
you in this I feel naked without my okay
not if I out stack you though I'm max
gentlemen you're Barnabas McManus yes so
there we go
on here who has any manners that's what
I really look like under my shirt by the
way just all muscles if I flexed once
like you would be exploded out of the
room at the force what are you doin to
the cathing or what are you doing to
that mysterious box over there that I
don't know what it is that what is that
I'm looking mallets play we did one
practice round should be good enough
yeah as we know I I would like to let
you know that I thought that's actually
exactly not true so lately destroyed
they're gonna believe that big that it's
not true at all I've won I was going
easy on you cuz I was just trying to
tell you how to do yeah all right let's
look at this why are we the same care i
stack the how we look identical right
now
what no let me I've got all the hats hey
okay oh you just won one hat for diner
it's alright it was not a great hat I'm
for the one right now you can't exactly
say that you're doing well in this
competition I have two hats what are you
talking about and are of higher quality
its quality oh my goodness you're just
lucky I quality hats uh uh what about
mine goodness that see I'm telling you
you're grabbing all of the loaf all of
you won't forget you're losing your high
quality that's that was me
yes it was my I was a threat shy love it
the Hat is mine it doesn't matter if
it's from the Crypt
as mine we're poor we can't afford very
expensive hats hope yeah I hope you know
aha you missed the beer how much am i
winning compared to you they're all
going to get knocked documents no
they're not
yep see we only have 50 seconds left in
the previous match wiring so many hats
it's because I'm better than you sir you
can have that one you can have that
thank you I know somehow I made it out
of that all right look at all these hats
I'm you need to speak closer ow you need
to speak closer I was concerned about
you look at all of these odds you're
making me miss oh oh you have darts in
the air as well whatever
I've only the dice did you catch up to
me I was doing just fine while you
traded one to get one so it doesn't
really matter on the side Wow I was
winning handedly and now I still am with
handedly like this oh I love me I win
Jordi you have lost I failed to accept
this I feel like we need a rematch Oh
best two out of three are you saying yes
I see that you say that very well I will
even I will even be I am a good sport I
will give you the hat to stack there you
go
I think that this just makes my job
harder than it was before exactly oh
okay why you do claim to be the expert
hat stacker okay so I'll just be like
this for the next rematch then that's so
maybe you could be another character I I
will try to be if you exist yeah I'll be
max gentleman you be
bonbon of the man Miss Manners you're
not quite as manly as me I dare say that
you didn't look properly at the screen
there I never looked rough
I only boldly don't because you lost all
your money and you can't afford to these
hazard well then excuse me don't play
without me here you also that's all
thank you for returning my hat you're
welcome
it sucked anyway it's not very nice I
got it I the bartender is favoring you
here we go I sometimes I get a little
bit excited and I it happens to the best
night get a hand to the floor it just
seems to happen to you more often than
me that's not exactly fair god damn this
you seem to be getting all the beer now
who's the bartender be horrid damage
while doing them it's light fancies me I
dare say oh he's gentlemanly Bart I
daresay I'm acquiring many a hatch
that's clap for you I don't last time
last time I learned that hats on
everything in life look at all these
hats that I've gotten oh oh my hat got
knocked in mine the bartender
what what did you bribe the bartender
with your last five-dollar bill yeah the
one that I'm not gonna give you when I
have to do something to give it to you
oh whatever
I forget what the original bet was so
I'm not entirely sure what it was a
pocket okay
Oh No Hey all right well mr. bartender
please I am in need of I'm really down
on my luck how smashed are our
characters getting by the way because
these aren't just beers these are kinds
of beer like full-on parties oh goodness
oh and this was mine
and that's mine and that's not mine you
know if we were smart we were just
drinking beers I had the beer do you
think that we would drink the beers that
are flying through the air cause it kind
of free pip laughs there we go what
gentleman doesn't pay for his own beer I
I allow the bartender to serve me on his
own
oh oh oh thank you for taking that for
me very gentlemanly of you to take the
bullet for me instead I am the winner
best two out of three by your own rules
I have one eye I accepted Faneuil square
I am gentlemanly enough to acknowledge
that you have bested me even if it would
only buy one hat good in fact if I took
this one back we would be dyed in fact I
would be in the lead by one okay except
as winner I get to shoot you in the foot
again bang you're not dead you just got
shot in the foot you two have to be here
ho gonna flop over and die would you get
shot at the foot I was overloaded by
stress and got a heart attack well I
would say that if you're not happy with
the result of this they'll have just
have to go over to CaptainSparklez
Channel and see the next round for
themselves what's it what is the
Internet I didn't say anything about
this Internet I don't know what you're
talking about
Oh hmm they know that yes forget that
mysterious entity that we're speaking to
right out but thank you so much for
watching this dispute and judging it
fairly I would say that I won but we can
only know when you go over didn't see
the other video maybe we tied we didn't
he knows the future of Bentley we
haven't done yet but I'm yeah just by
knowing me bang you're not dead why do
you keep dying bang bye-bye
mm-hmm you know I lost all my money
because of you so did I were in the same
boat how the hell did that happen
one of us one well frigerator running
yes I do
where are you going with this nice tie
did you tie yourself for once
looks like you were trying to make a
noose looks a little bit better than
your circus bowtie the pony goes round
the hill and goes under and comes out
that's how we were all taught don't make
fun of me
looks like the bunny got his head
trapped in the earth and died Koff your
bunny I don't have one anymore because
you killed it probably I've had a girl
Jesus
I'm so sorry yeah I'm gonna call it
Google Google clue what bugle clue it
means over a hundred billion does it no
blue and I'm familiar with a blue eye
it's what my horses turned into I know
yes I lost all the bets and then they
would turn to just like I got a bike
could pick that up so what did you do
waste all of your money on cheap
prostitutes Oh going with the
prostitutes again I thought we weren't
talking about your mother anymore my
mother was a prostitute she's no longer
yeah because she's not good enough to be
paid at all well I'm going to dig entire
family out of a bankruptcy with my new
venture that involves squashing you I'm
gonna dig them out of the graves that
they buried themselves in after they
killed themselves help on problems of
you were they were
oh god damn it
who's so me to him please you threw
everyone rounded them see you still have
the same hat you had before
no slightly different just a little
worse that that's not even a good insult
Oh sharp [ __ ] well it looks like you've
taken after your mother I remember she
was so fat she ate gout for breakfast
how do you eat doubt that doesn't even
make sense your poorness must have
affected your mind
see how I upgraded my hat even when I am
at my lowest point I still keep up with
style so in other words you prioritize
your looks over actually having money
yes of course I that [ __ ] didn't gallons
of beer that I had laying next to me
before I stumbled into you what come
please horse hockey you couldn't afford
a single beer after the thrashing I gave
you in the last round at least I have a
tie that's properly done as opposed to
yours I have said I keep up with the
proper stylings of the day even in my
nose destitute [ __ ] I'm done okay hey
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it all